hi Kylie Jenner and Khloe Kardashian
adjusted their makeup drunk together and
it's exactly the kind of news the world
needs right now
no but seriously it really is the best
video of all time hi I'm Kylie and we
are doing a drunk they're ready with us
using my birthday collection in the clip
posted to Kylie's YouTube channel the
famous sisters down shots of tequila
like a lot of tequila I told you I'm
both taking 8 to 10 shots while taking
back shots like season champs the
sisters do a makeup tutorial using
products from Kylie cosmetics new
birthday Collection in honor of Kylie's
22nd birthday so honestly I've never
done my makeup intoxicated Khloe and
Kylie break the cardinal rule of
drinking and make a few very drunk phone
calls it just tastes so bad they hit up
Chloe's bestie Malika their sister Kim
who was with Saint north and Kanye
West's mama Kris Jenner and even Scott
Disick's girlfriend Sophia Ricci who
stops by the shoot later on
we're in each other's maker now we're
supposed to do our own yeah I think we
did too much and yep that's Chris's man
Cory gamble so know what that means what
okay but back to the hot mess Express
gluey focus makeup no it's never gonna
happen okay well it did happen and I
wouldn't exactly call it their best work
but A for effort girls hi guys you guys
this was the worst idea Kylie took to
Instagram to announce that the video had
dropped calling the experience a night
to remember and here my favorite sister
don't tell the rest then Chloe hit up
the comments section writing quote Oh No
lol I genuinely do not remember about
halfway through this video and on thank
you for coming with me
well it looks like Kylie's birthday is
already off to a really good start
happy birthday you billionaire you of
course
et will be here to help you keep up with
the Kardashian Jenner's so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Haley Stephens bye for now
[Music]